a protest raging out of control violent
clashes with the police
an officer gravely wounded after being
stabbed by an Islamic extremist the
German agency for the protection of the
Constitution believes that salafists
pose a very serious danger desk aphelion
desert in my opinion the danger of this
situation lies in the radicalization of
individuals leading to militant actions
and stabbings like those we've seen in
England and France salafists are also
believed to be behind an attempted
bombing a Kanban Central Station last
winter four men were arrested in
connection with the planned strike a
short time ago not all Salafist actions
are violent sometimes adherents hand out
free copies of the Koran like these
young men in 2012 the movements members
claimed to be the only ones living a
truly Muslim life is LOM experts ghido
Steinberg says salafism is still a
fringe phenomenon in Germany there are a
lot of Salafists in germany who are only
concerned with living life in literal
accordance with the seventh century
prophet and his disciples in Mecca and
Medina no one takes much notice of them
around 4 million Muslims live in Germany
but only about five to ten thousand of
them are classified as salafists and out
of those say police only a few are
radical enough to pose a threat
those few attract a lot of media
attention radicals however don't play
big roles and established Muslim
communities it is a nail salon not some
high social boon these neo Salafists use
platforms like the internet or dialectic
and black and white thinking but when it
comes to long-term outreach work they're
nowhere to be found
that's why mosques have very little to
do with
salafists MIT Salafist Osasuna yet
they're convincing more and more people
to join their ranks in Islam the
movement is growing faster than almost
any other in countries like Tunisia
Egypt and Germany we have someone on our
side
Allah simple messages an effective way
of drawing new adherents from other
religions as well as Muslims with less
radical backgrounds salafism is
attractive to many Muslims here in
Germany in the same way that it's
perhaps cool to be right-wing in some
areas of East Germany or East Westphalia
it's cool for young Muslims in big
cities to be Salafist some of these
German salafists have set out for Syria
intelligence services have information
suggesting that around 50 of them are
taking part in the civil war there
they're returned to Germany could have
an effect on the country's radical
movement these people come back more
radical than when they left they have
experience and are trained in the use of
weapons explosives and so on at the same
time they're heroes among their peers
and can mobilize people police raids
have uncovered many hints of planned
attacks and murders some Salafist
organizations have been banned the
members of the Central Council of
Muslims in Germany feels the problem has
landed squarely on their shoulders Hans
legume ayat the communities have to
prepare themselves because salafists are
trying to recruit they know that they
have no chance of initiating any
programs in the mosques but they will
try to win over individuals this is a
problem for the communities
it's a problem that must be dealt with
by both Muslim communities and the
authorities a simple band won't be
enough to stop extremists
[Music]